on est on est prêts on a fait faire tous
les éléments qui vont permettre aux gens
de repérer les voitures qui seront qui
seront éligibles à la prime à la
conversion
lorsque lorsque le décrit ses rangs
sortie on n'attend plus que le top
départ pour les coller sur les véhicules
chez ce concessionnaire on se dit prêt
bien calé dans les starting blocks
mais il ya un hic le frein est de
rigueur faute d'informations précises
on connaît les grandes lignes on sait
qu'il faut que ce soit des gens qui sont
non imposables que ça va représenter les
20% des personnes les plus modestes mais
on ne sait pas exactement ce que ça veut
dire
on sait qu'il va falloir que les gens
fassent 60 km pour venir travailler mais
on ne sait pas si c'est un une seule
fois ci c'est en comptant le trajet de
midi si c'est uniquement un aller retour
donc on est dans l'expectative et
malheureusement on aimerait avoir plus
d'informations pour pouvoir répondre à
nos clients les clients téléphone mais
pour l'heure ils sont invités à rappeler
plus tard faute de décret officiel on
savoir s'ils pourront bénéficier d'une
prime à la conversion pouvant aller
jusqu'à 4000 voire 5000 euros pour les
foyers les plus modestes non imposables
selon leur choix véhicules essence ou
diesel électrique ou hybride hybride ce
sont les modèles principalement défendu
chez cet autre concessionnaire
le nouveau dispositif aujourd'hui va
surtout permettre en tout cas
d'anticiper
aux revenus non imposables d'anticiper
leurs changements en matière de
véhicules les plus modestes vont
s'orienter majoritairement vers le
marché de l'occasion reste à savoir si
le montant de la prime sera suffisant
pour entraîner des renouvellements de
véhicules plus écologiques
réponse dans quelques mois